bullet cat podcast man black boy jb in
here but my guy said he's in rapper mode
hit that
push c's
yeah
push the c's
[Music]
got these chains on i'm feeling like i'm
missing black nation got fruity gun
banana clip lemon squeeze i'm pushing c
so [ __ ] that ain't no [ __ ] ever shot at
blocking he ain't bust back we don't
speak on bodies this [ __ ] police can't
discuss that got so many gunners they be
asking me what the
tummy in my hand i just might kill your
favorite rugrat catch him loaf and spit
his hat spin his block straight back to
back every single problem that i had i
did some math today catch her off and
subtract and i will not divide with none
of my [ __ ] and that's facts i'm fat i
got all probation grind my draco like
it's been a minute mom said don't get
dizzy in the hood cause i've been out
here spinning all my life i've been a
man of god but i've been irritant and
used to working pop out now pop eyes
when they see me when it's blocked
hey i know you just watched the crazy
freestyle appreciate you watching make
sure you subscribe and make sure
you show some love to our folks at lrg
clothing man listen
i've been [ __ ] with lrg since i was
in high school and they are still doing
their [ __ ] thing all right and i got
something special for you 30 off your
next order at lrg
all you got to do is use the keyword and
by keyword i mean promo code
use the promo code kev 30. that's kev
3-0 we're gonna put the website right
there you see it right there
l dash r dash g
dot com all right we'll put the website
right there cook put the website right
there
save you 30 off one more time use that
promo code kev30 on lrg's website for
your chance well not your chance you'll
actually get 30 off it's not like it's a
[ __ ] contest just use the code and
you got it all right shout out to lrg